grandma thora I mean Yuri after a drawl
today with Marty's Ashley yes before we
get to that draw we do want to ask about
this $10 savings that you had I know
your boyish good looks but you're not as
young as your kid no no but I still
counter so I mean I think what what Amir
was so contrasting my my coach
so contrasting they're probably like on
his the next he might look like a baby I
don't know maybe for all we know maybe
Rex arranged the whole thing
pulling the strings and some of the
dollars are there and then you went into
the best that you got $10 which didn't
really count as a confession this $10
extra content the $10 extra see my coach
also reason as a child then though well
this game you seem to have a little
something but Maxime as Yasir says or is
spittin yeah so like the joke group of
lawyers seem like they don't feel happy
unless they're down upon and somehow
Mike Seema once again is able to defend
this position yeah if I mean I had a
sort of a clear pawn in the center and
it wasn't really hanging but I allowed
this Bishop takes c3 I'm acoustic sought
to be honest I'm is that a very
beautiful idea but actually despite that
I missed it I was actually happy to get
the end game but then I sort of decided
to tempt him into capturing my age for
pawn only to realize that I had a nice
strap there which he actually didn't see
but turns out that there is this defense
of switching the road back to defile I
mean I mean my calculation I was sort of
stopped we have we have this week and I
see three if you go move back I mean I
can play any move I mean I can play I
don't know Queen c2 rook c8 Queen d3 or
I can even play couldn't be won maybe I
mean I can just as long as he cannot
capture on d5 because of Knight f4 I'm
happy but I thought Knight c3 was just
very strong
I mean I can do this and then people
probably go back and forth with the rook
and maybe it somewhere to go I don't
know h5 / B should be five make some
waiting moves and I have to sort of find
a way to proceed somehow I was wondering
how to regroup and I thought okay nice
it was a very nice opportunity for me
because I thought he but he I miss this
Quincy six idea and at first I was so
shocked I thought that maybe I can
wander it into a drawer something but at
least I have this deep own but basically
I can play how I played it I can let's
say start with even f3 let's say it's at
the veg for if I want I didn't I
actually didn't think he was gonna go
active with the rook I thought he has to
wait with Bishop one to seven look on
the eighth-ranked and then I was
wondering how to push it's very hard I
think I can try but it it probably is a
draw but it's very hard to win and I was
thinking okay h4 is probably nice to
have but then in the game he suddenly
got it suddenly got to the room before I
thought it doesn't work because of F
because a bishop before and I didn't see
a roguish wore it first I saw king f7
which he mentioned after the game as
well but it's actually what I was hoping
for after king f7 I've got f3 he takes
on h4 and then I have rook e1 Bishop e6
which is so because this ever would be
probably I have g4 here and actually
have winning here and in fact he missed
this whole thing which is which is a
huge pity for me because you know game
would happen and then differently here
but he has this other way which I from
afar miss I mean I was just calculating
in my head that my route gets to the
seventh rank and then the pole promotes
but of course he has this loop de for
Bishop fi f h5 setup and then I cannot
do anything to be honestly I don't know
how big my chances are I was kind of on
purpose slightly tempting him to capture
the h4 point because deep inside I
probably thought that if I consolidated
even I'll probably still not be able to
press forward so I thought maybe let's
hope for some tricks but in hindsight if
I would have stopped this looking for
thing I don't know I mean how to win
this position I have to probably go out
and on g4 at some point maybe try to
create a second front somewhere but it's
very very hard we were still thinking
that
my play g3 you rejected it yeah I had to
I mean I still blundered this I was
hoping for our King of seven after
Bishop before okay
I thought be sure before km7 f3 if you
will have to go back with the rook and
we have the position that we have and
then I'd rather not go g3 I mean I'd
rather I rather coking of two and rather
put my king on you see if I need I don't
know but basically I should have gone g3
of course compared to what I have done
sure let me ask you part of your
confession included sort of blessing to
lavon's Bishop on stage yeah I'm
surprised the guy is still alive and I
was only six after the six it looked
like this is not gonna be the game of
the seat bishop okay I heard my
confession and a good priest decided to
answer up and this event has featured a
number of draws fighting chess but draws
nevertheless only one win so far few
games pending open for decisive result
that is not you hoping for decisive
result you no doubt hope that they just
keep drawing at least this round but
pennies Malaysian it's quite interesting
I mean you usually people sort of
obviously blame the players but then you
cannot do that here because we had
exactly the same field in the Croatia
right so you got to blame something else
because I was there too so I cannot
blame neither just in case you've
decided to blame me again for all this
for all the sins we were wondering maybe
it's a combination of like little time
to prepare before the game in the
morning because in Croatia we started
much later so there wasn't much more
time to prepare and then when you have
so little time you probably are more
likely to do something safe and at the
same time it's very hot outside as well
it was hot and crazy I think even in the
play in fact people were complaining
that the reason why there's so many
decisive games was because it was so hot
in playing room that you guys couldn't
think that it was hot during the game so
we could make mistakes but fear is like
on the way like you go from the hotel
you had no time in panic you Russia
you're just in time to put your jacket
so you're running and this only you
enter the street and it's so hot and you
are so happy to reach the playing well
you already just wanna just come make a
drawing go back I mean I think one thing
is that Magnus haven't started winning
yet he is usually a short guy too
and the weight usually when there is
someone already who gets going the
others try to catch up so I think Magnus
will win today and things will unfold
you think this religion is winning
nobody reminds me very much of this game
he won't encourage against ding leader
he's got this bishop pair and I mean
they just hire you wait let's take a
look at this is your size position at
Division the question is only how is why
drawing as long as why it doesn't draw
this one I mean unlike my force will be
shut before and then I think the answer
came up with a very powerful plan the
idea of trying to play for Bishop e4
Queen e2 which would be for if you if
you insist on putting a bishop on e5 you
mean a fiver yes there's about five we
need to yeah and if there's Queen d7
here instead of Bishop a5 yeah I should
probably not put the bishop on the five
because then I get into the straight yes
isn't there an h3 here just like mating
yes Queen h3 is a double threat no I
mean you know it reminds me that game
will be there and what's very important
is that these bishops have to be like as
back as possible so the one on c8 is
very good they're better not to employ
Bishop a5 however yeah Queen d7 and
Queen h3 that had more then just walk
around us if you put the Queen there you
know it protects against e6 after Bishop
a5 and then Bishop e4 even one Bishop
against the night is still better
because of the outside postponed but I I
like the screen to 7
I thought you still have the same
feeling that after Bishop f5 Magnus will
win but we need to if I play Queen e7 I
was wondering should I play g4 or not
I'm not I'm not actually sure myself
Queen e2 we need 7 let's say maybe 7
getting DePandi's freaking a 3 bishop
before very desperate at least you
activate I mean now you've got the heart
harmony with white you just missing upon
see I like this for well I mean not like
but like I think it's an approval
solution suddenly the 93 be sure before
it's all beautiful yes good drawing
chances chances and also there's a G for
those not underestimate that the
tournaments they have certain hour so or
of this tournament is like they're like
been way too many drawers so then people
are likely to somehow mess things up you
know it's like when there are too many
drawers happening in the round like
somehow people are more likely to make a
draw I don't know I've noticed it before
let me ask you a question did you take a
look at the online game against Wesley
yeah I thought it was just winning on
somehow on my force and opening now and
when after see for Queen a5 it must be a
win there right mm-hmm
definitely was a win there I mean I
wasn't sure but at that point I had to
come up with my own position so I
decided but I was really about to get
carried away I put the position up she
was the right to deny before yeah
because the point is Bishop takes and
Queen takes before is very important
yeah now I was wondering here about
various various things I was absolutely
sure that what is winning here so what
are your thoughts what are you thoughts
about what this work workers through
your your process so first Bishop before
Queen before I considered I thinking of
one
there was some issue with this though
Queen has to move yeah yeah but what's
this shoulda c5 say we're a for quitting
for your spinning for was issue and then
the Queen a 524 yeah that was the issue
okay yeah okay I was consider also rook
takes but then Bishop takes d5 about nh6
I think you calculate it will be three
yes III I thought Queenie
- exactly alright
we just want to gauge how difficult it
is for an elite player to find you know
I saw this thing when the Wesley first
of all announced that he likes tests and
then also just solved it I dislike this
it's not easy because Rishi is booked on
Twitter and he was thinking there over
15 minutes yeah she didn't he didn't see
it you're not so what are your
candidates I'm curious about that
position again
what are your so you looked at two moves
who so far but should be four and Queen
Queen b3
well yes are prompted yeah what other
moves would you be looking at right now
your candidate yeah this you just off
the top of your head are all Queen moves
are sort of to be considered okay how so
just give just give us a couple the
queen of finish three whenever there's
the reckoning stage six the queen of
three looks a bit more next howdy please
thank you would you follow this line
uneasy would you what would you stop I
think I think at this I think he stopped
and I mean you sort of yeah okay so we
have a running argument on the show and
yeah so sir Juan in all his wisdom feels
like he's you know there's certain moves
that are easy for for players to find
and I argue that it's not easy to find
the move that is is the strong move here
is not an easy move even for strong
fighters even consider in fact we have
follow something on there you go we have
one here yeah and see fine after stick
with this that's not so easy is it
yeah capable sure but that's actually it
yeah could've fallen that's actually it
your your view on the rook is protected
it's very nice to be one Ruby's protect
us or NATO is not even an option
no Queen a2 is an option to the best
option
five no see if I have to get it done
either because you see other yeah you're
still just surviving you have to find
the next move which is well maybe he saw
a man couldn't Falconeri - yeah yeah the
movies the movies rookie one in that
position and then bring the Queen back
in there - and then go okay that's too
much that is very hard yeah yeah you
might have seen queen of one itself
connect or rank you on this yellow and
now we get to game position and looks
like it is going to be a draw and this
she will not win as good defense will
hold the day that on this server yeah
it's just it's a pity it's like a bit
like my game like you deserve to press
midwives despite all the stupidity of
your C but somehow we didn't even get to
press that's very unfair exactly well
thank you very much for joining us we
appreciate it and good luck tomorrow
thank you and we won't give you any more
- if you go to the confessional back to
our problem otherwise they'll be test
the war down there